قبل اشهر بدا ديسانتوس المرشح الجمهوري
الاوفر حظا كانت ترامب لا يزال في دوامه
تحقيق وثائق منتجع ميرلاكو وظهر الشاب
الايطالي الاصل في صوره
شابه واكثر حماسه اليوم انقلبت الصوره
ترامب يتفوق بنسبه 20% عن ملاحقه ديسانتوس
في استطلاعات الراي وهناك اسباب عده
والسبب الاول حرب اوكرانيا
ديسانس اعتبر ان الحرب الاوكرانيه تخص
اوروبا وحدها خصومه اعتبروه بلا انعزالي
وذلك في وقت قال فيه ترامب انه يستطيع وقف
هذه الحرب خلال اربع وعشرين ساعه سبب اخر
اتهم ديسانتوس بانه مناهض للشركات بسبب
معاركه مع شركه ديزني ترامب جاء في صف
الشركه وراى انها تسحق ديسانتس وضربه
الاخيره كانت بيدي ديسانتوس نفسه
وقع على قرار بحظر الاجهاض بعد سته اسابيع
من الحمل في سلوريدا قرار وصفه ترامب
للمتطرف خصوصا وان غالبيه الجمهوريين
يؤيدون فتره السته اشهر بحسب استطلاعات
الراي
بلدنا يسير في الاتجاه الخاطئ يمكننا ان
نرى الامر وان نشعر به لقد انهارت حدودنا
الجنوبيه تمتلك عصابات المخدرات المكسيكيه
سيطره اكبر على ما يجري على الحدود اكثر
من حكومتنا في الولايات المتحده الملايين
من الاجانب غير الشرعيين تدفقوا الى
بلادنا
كره اقناع قاعده ترامب الشعبيه بانه يمثل
نسخه اكثر التزاما وانضباطا من الرئيس
السابق منافسه رئاسيه ثالثه وهي نيكي هيلي
تحدثت عن الامر حمله ديسانس كلها قائمه
على تقليد ترامب لدرجه ان حمله هذه نشرت
فيديو يوضح اوجه الشبه بين ترامب
وديسانتوس
[موسيقى]
انسان
يقدم المرشح الجمهوري رونالدو
محافظ مثل ترامب لكن من دون اخطائه وانه
يمتلك سجلا حافلا بانجازات متعلقه بقيم
محافظه حققها خلال مسيرته السياسيه كتسهيل
امتلاك السلاح وتقييد تعليم الهويه
الجنسيه في المدارس وتشديد قواعد التصويت
في الانتخابات والحد من عمليات الاجهاض
ويركز دستنتس على انه يفوز دائما ويشير
الى انه لم يهزم في سباقات الكونجرس او
منصب حاكم فلوريدا ويرفض ما يصفها بثقافه
الخساره التي اثرت على الحزب الجمهوري في
السنوات الاخيره معتبرا ان وقت الاعذار قد
ولى مزايا تجعل نظريا على الاقل مرشحا
يمكنه التغلب على ترامب المتقدمه على جميع
المرشحين الجمهوريين حاليا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات